on this episode I talk about piss-poor
things double consumption and my last
five breaths in my life
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the askgaryvee
anyone is gary vay-ner-chuk and welcome
to episode 40 of the askgaryvee show
otto asked i like how you talk about
execution in business how do you
prioritize which project to execute
first o - a great question by the way
real quick thank you everybody for
getting me to 40 also all the people
watching I need you to get into the
podcast podcast evil watch I want people
listening and watching every episode is
that too much to ask that he had this
double consumption it's double
consumption that's a hashtag I want to
see if any of you use it on Twitter
uh-oh - the the way I prioritize is to
equally with my intuition so it's a
judgment call equally take care of the
things that are most on fire the biggest
problems balanced with going on the
offense on the biggest upside things and
the biggest things the culture a new
client so take care of these three
employees that are fighting and they're
not getting along really you know on
fire or a client that's really upset and
then over here strike the vision what
are we doing at the video department
where are we going like what am i doing
like where is this all going how do I
buy the Jets and nothing in the middle
ohto vaynernation the middle is
dangerous he only asks before you had an
assistant how did you structure your day
the only first of all I just wanted to
tell you I appreciate all the
interaction thanks for being a supporter
of the askgaryvee show by the way back
to the last question the middle is
dangerous a pre assistant I mean it was
a disaster
I had this power position at Wine
Library where I was one of the biggest
wine buyers in the world were definitely
in the u.s. in the world and and nothing
to got to my head but I was like look
somebody could wait 15 minutes or 20
minutes if I'm like you know finishing
up this meeting they're here to sell me
so I I kind of took them you know the
buyers approach mentality to that go
who's bad was I would triple booked
people like literally I used to be like
on the floor at 11:30 in the morning
helping somebody with you know a big
selection for a party and I'd see like
somebody walking him like oh yeah that's
right I have a meeting with Chris
and I'd be like yeah and you should try
this Pinot Noir and then I'd be like oh
crap why did Frank just come in that's
right I have a meeting with Frank and I
think it's at the same time that's bad
let me figure out what I'm gonna do and
by the way you need a little cheese for
your party
why did Sally just walk in holy crap I'm
triple-booked and this would happen a
lot and it was complete chaos
it was disorganized it wasn't efficient
and it was piss-poor dee asked if you
were to jump in a time machine travel
back to speak to your 21 year old self
and only have one minute what do you say
Z I would tell that person to hook up
with more chicks and not work as many
hours and I know that can be crass and I
and obviously you know what what that
crass statement is really saying is have
a little more fun right you're gonna
accomplish your things you're gonna pull
it off you know we appreciate that you
do have business patience but you need
to spend a little bit more time with
your friends you can go on one more
vacation you can go do a keg stand you
need to live a little bit because you're
gonna have a family which is gonna be
amazing you're gonna be busy as crap and
you're gonna run out of this time you're
only 21 once Tiger asks if your dad
Sasha would have ended up in
construction how do you think it would
have affected your life without Wine
Library Tiger a great question and by
the way this is a big shout out of 40
for everybody who's asking for a little
bit more condensed we're keeping it
tight on the 400 I wish I said to 21
year old self to drink more 40s that
would have tied in then anyway Tiger you
know what I think about this a lot and
I'm gonna I promised myself and you guys
have heard me talk about this to be
honest on this show and this is tough
for me to say there's a big part of me
that thinks I'd be more successful if I
didn't go into the family business I
wouldn't have had the head start that
many people can say I had and I respect
that but my intuition tells me that I
would have been even a little more
hustler right maybe maybe to a bad
degree but I could see myself my
intuition and I thought about this a lot
by the way is that I would have head out
west during the Internet boom I probably
would have had a company worth 800
million dollars going public in 1999
that would have went to $1.00 in stock
value but I would have learned things in
that
might have made me bet even harder on
Facebook and Twitter and uber than I did
and so you know my intuition may be
because I've ego maybe because I have
bravado is if my dad didn't have an
amazing set up for me to go into if I
didn't fall in love with the family
business and want to be a part of it
don't forget I was making a lot of money
selling baseball cards I could have went
down that route
there's just I feel like I would have
really found my way and I feel that my
dad taught me honor and a lot of
conservativeness that has helped me not
veer off or have losses but I think
sucked out a little bit of my speed and
aggressiveness and that may sound weird
to you guys but I do believe that and I
and I do wonder if man I might have been
more financially along however and this
let me put this new mistake in the
ground it's the best thing that ever
happened to me because forget about the
money's those those 10 years
specifically when I was full time of
spending that many hours with my dad
when I'm on my last breath when I'm
laying there and I'm dying there's no
question in my mind that those will be
one of the two or three things obviously
all the things I'm about to have with my
kids and probably a selfish thing about
how many Super Bowls I won but like you
know those that those ten years with my
dad will definitely 100% be one of the
final five thoughts as I die and to me
that is an incredible accomplishment and
something I'm grateful for and very
thankful for my friends thank you for
watching episode 4 Oh question of the
day this is a big one this is a this if
you're listening if you're watching you
need to pass this on to the other
vaynernation I'm making this an iconic
question this is a ten year question let
me explain why in the answers on YouTube
I want you to predict the amount of
shows that the askgaryvee show will have
all-time final curtain it will happen
I'm sorry how many episodes of the
askgaryvee show will I produce and a
year or two after it's over I will go
back and look at the comments team and
we will pick everybody who guessed
correctly and invite them to dinner with
me you keep
any questions I'll keep answering them
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe